[Musique]
dans les profondeurs les plus noirs de
l'esprit existent une cage dont les
prisonniers ne savent ni qui ils sont ni
combien ils sont
de cette cellule la fuite est difficile
ce sont des personnes qui souffrent du
trouble de la personnalité multiple de
dépression de suicides de changement de
personnalité ou de perte de mémoire
[Musique]
durant des années ils étaient incompris
et non soignés encore aujourd'hui nul ne
sait pourquoi l'esprit se dérègle en
plusieurs personnalités au lieu d'une
normalement
[Musique]
l'origine de l'arrivée de la
personnalité multiple vient souvent de
l'enfance mais se développe beaucoup
plus tard
[Musique]
les dérèglements surviennent
généralement après une expérience
traumatisante
un matin de janvier 1988 Gary infirmier
de 41 ans dans le Wisconsin se réveille
et fixe sa femme d'un œil vide
[Musique]
Thierry s'est réveillé en regardant tout
autour de lui les ragars de celui qui ne
sait plus où il est ou qu'il est
terrible choc ce n'était pas Gary
c'était quelqu'un d'autre un autre homme
que je ne connaissais pas la voix de
Gary était plus douce avec des
atolations féminines sa femme Catherine
se sentait de plus en plus effrayée
au lieu de s'habiller avec les vêtements
de Gary cette personne est allée dans ma
penderie pour prendre mes vêtements
alors je me suis dit
il faut que je sache ce qui se passe et
surtout je dois éloigner Gary de la
maison nous avons donc rouler au hasard
toute la journée n'apporte tout
Garry disait à Catherine qu'il n'avait
aucune idée de qui elle était ni de
leurs six enfants mais ils prétendait
être une femme s'appelant mairie
j'ai cru que Gary était devenu fou
complètement fou mais ce ne pouvait être
Gary cette personne ne connaissait pas
les enfants ne savaient rien de sa vie
un paumé un véritable paumé
pour un homme travailleur aimant sa
femme et ses enfants ce n'était plus
l'homme qu'il avait épousé 20 ans plus
tôt
[Musique]
quand Catherine et Gary était jeune et
nouveau mari il savait exactement ce
qu'il voulait une grande famille et une
petite laiterie des enfants dès les
premières années étaient tout ce qu'ils
avaient souhaité
je me souviendrai toujours de nos
pique-niques de nos balades de nos
parties de foot parce que mon père était
toujours dans le cou mes meilleurs
souvenirs sont toujours nous nous tous
ensemble juste dans le bonheur simple
d'être en famille
[Musique]
mais ce bonheur a été brisé à l'annonce
du cancer du cerveau de leur fille aînée
Crissy
âgé de 8 ans
les docteurs lui donnaient quelques
semaines à vivre
mais écris si les a fait mentir en
s'accrochant à la vie
Gary et Catherine passèrent tout leur
temps à s'occuper de leur fille aînée
mais les frais médicaux entraînèrent
leur faillite et en 1978 ils sont
obligés de louer une petite maison à
pleine ville dans le Wisconsin
[Musique]
4 ans plus tard Christie contracte une
pneumonie et doit être emmené d'urgence
à l'hôpital toute la nuit Gary devant sa
porte
au petit matin pendant l'introduction
d'un moniteur cardiaque critique est un
arrêt cardiaque
Gary a regardé impuissance la fille
mourir malgré les efforts de réanimation
TCF
avait enfoncé un couteau dans le cœur
rien n'est comparable à cette douleur
c'est horrible
c'est sans doute à ce moment-là que la
personnalité de Gary a commencé à
vaciller
ce fut un terrible vide dans la vie de
Gary et Catherine
[Musique]
Catherine s'était réfugié dans les
livres tandis que Gary semblait préparer
ce changement brutal de personnalité
à l'âge de 36 ans Gary qui n'avait
jamais été excellent à l'école car
dyslexique vous les reprendre des études
de médecine
[Musique]
le changement des deux parents
inquiétait leurs enfants
dans sa chambre et papa Jamila soit
chercher du travail soit il travaillait
soit il étudier
[Musique]
la famille vécue ainsi durant 5 ans
jusqu'à l'obtention d'un diplôme
universitaire pour Gary et d'un autre
traumatisme qui cette fois le ferait
basculer
le médecin de Catherine lui annonce
qu'elle était atteinte d'un cancer des
ovaires face terminale il s'avère très
vite que le diagnostic était une erreur
Catherine ne courait en réalité aucun
danger mais pour Gary c'était plus qu'il
n'en pouvait supporter la pensée qu'il
aurait pu perdre aussi sa femme d'un
cancer la briser
[Musique]
je suis rentré de l'hôpital exténué il
m'avait été annoncé que je devais mourir
vous accusez le coup
puis c'est même médecin vous annonce que
tout va bien
je me suis sentie comme anesthésier puis
je ne me souviens plus de rien à son
réveil le lendemain Catherine trouve un
étranger à côté d'elle dans son lit qui
lui dit s'appelait mairie
Catherine devenue méfiante à l'égard de
tous les docteurs ne le conduit pas chez
un psychiatre
[Musique]
si je n'avais pas eu des problèmes avec
ici et mes propres problèmes peut-être
aurais-je agi différemment mais à
l'époque j'avais peur des médecins
j'aurais dû foncer à l'hôpital
après une semaine de vie totale Gary a
quitté sa maison pour vivre dans le
Milwaukee trouvant un appartement et un
travail et menant la vie d'une femme
[Musique]
plus tard Gary prendra une autre
personnalité celle d'un bébé et sa
maladie mystérieuse sera finalement
diagnostiquée
[Musique]
par un froid matin de février 1988 une
famille du Wisconsin perdra son père non
à la suite d'un décès ou d'un divorce
mais à la suite d'un cas de personnalité
multiple non encore diagnostiqué
[Musique]
Gary a quitté son domicile en disant
être une femme nommée merrée il a
déménagé dans le Milwaukee et a
travaillé dans une exploitation
d'équipements lourds tous ces nouveaux
amis pensaient qu'il était une femme
c'était effectivement une forte femme
mais elle était bien coiffée bien
maquillée les ongles faits elle
dégageait de la douceur de la réserve et
possédait une grande féminité
mais une petite ville comme celle que
Gary avait quitté n'était pas prête à
accepter cette mystérieuse
transformation les voisins considéraient
Gary comme un travesti ou un fou
[Musique]
Catherine a pensé trouver une aide au
sein de son église catholique mais elle
a été rejetée
[Musique]
les gens de mon propre groupe de prière
ont abandonné devant le tabernacle l'un
d'entre eux m'a même dit vous feriez
mieux de prier avec nous et là j'ai
plutôt pensé oh mon dieu
Catherine fut forcée de vivre en recluse
que voulez-vous que nous fassions
comment les enfants pouvaient-ils dire à
leurs voisins et amis mon père est parti
et maintenant c'est une personne qui
porte des robes
j'ai menti à tout le monde Gary était
parti dans le Milwaukee et si quelqu'un
avait voulu plus de détails je lui
aurais dit qu'il était quelque part et
que je ne savais pas où
trois mois après le départ de Gary
d'échecs et de gentils lettres demandant
des nouvelles des enfants sont arrivés à
la maison elles étaient toutes signées
mairies
jusqu'à quel point Marie se souvenait
qu'elle avait une famille il s'adressait
à moi comme à une sœur
[Musique]
mais Catherine ne se doutait pas encore
de ce qu'il a devenait de son mari
[Musique]
Gary a vécu comme mairie jusqu'à ce
qu'il se sentent un peu perturbé et
recherche l'aide d'un psychothérapeute
elle est arrivée à la clinique et tout
de suite j'ai vu dans son regard ce
désordre intérieur qui l'animait
s'appelait mairie ne comprenait pas
pourquoi il avait des organes masculins
les évaluations psychologiques ont
montré qu'il avait eu des trous de
mémoire énorme et qui ne se souvenait de
rien avant son fameux réveil de ce matin
auprès de sa femme Catherine
je lui ai demandé si elle pouvait
appeler un membre de sa famille pour
parler avec nous car je ne savais plus
quoi faire d'autre
a décidé de ne pas revoir le thérapeute
mais de rester en contact avec Catherine
Catherine voulant maintenir la relation
avec son époux et devenu la meilleure
amie de mairie
[Musique]
en deux ans Catherine a réussi à
convaincre mairie de venir vivre avec
elle et les enfants ils ont acheté une
vieille ferme et quelques vaches
laitières
les enfants étaient d'accord pour
appeler leur père tente mairie mais
cette solution fut dévastatrice
[Musique]
je faisais des caprices pour ne pas
aller à l'école je disais que mon père
en était la cause et que je pensais que
je n'arriverai jamais à rien mais en
réalité si je pleurais beaucoup c'est
que je ne voulais tout simplement pas
sortir de chez moi parce qu'à ce
moment-là les gens ont vraiment été
méchants avec moi ils vécurent ainsi
trois années difficiles abandonné par
les parents et les amis Catherine
désespérée de trouver un jour une
solution à son problème mairie accepte
enfin de retourner voir son
psychothérapeute Gretch and finger
Catherine l'accompagnera
alors Catherine a commencé à me raconter
ce qui s'était vraiment passé et j'ai
pensé qu'il ne s'agissait pas d'un
trouble d'identité mais de quelque chose
du même genre
ce quelque chose du même genre est
devenu beaucoup plus clair ce matin ou
Gary menant encore la vie d'une femme
nommée merie c'est électrocuté en
faisant des travaux à la ferme
[Musique]
lorsqu'elle a ouvert les yeux j'ai vu un
étranger ce regard perdu qui cette fois
encore ne me reconnaissait pas
cet homme de 47 ans pouvait à peine
parler et marcher Gary n'était plus Mary
c'était désormais un bébé
Catherine a appelé Gretchen Fink qui lui
a conseillé de foncer à l'hôpital
devant la peur de Catherine Fink a bien
voulu les retrouver là-bas
je suis entrée dans la pièce et j'ai vu
cette personne que je connaissais depuis
maintenant 5 ans qui me regardait comme
si elle ne m'avait jamais vu c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai pensé aux troubles de
la personnalité multiple
dès qu'une personne présente deux
personnalités totalement distinctes elle
peut être considérée comme possédant ce
trouble psychologique en devenant un
bébé après avoir été une femme on savait
de quoi souffrait guéri
si c'était un soulagement pour la
famille ce n'était pas une guérison pour
garer il s'occupait de lui comme d'un
bébé il buvait des biberons et manger la
nourriture des nourrissons
puis à matin 8 semaines plus tard aussi
mystérieusement qu'il avait disparu Gary
est revenu
nous n'avons ni vu ni parler à Gary et
tout d'un coup il s'est réveillé
son dernier souvenir était celui de la
mort de sa fille Christie
à cette attaque j'ai dit ils ont tué
elle était à l'hôpital des internes ont
voulu lui poser un simulateur cardiaque
sans autorisation
c'était en pleine nuit et ils ont
provoqué un arrêt cardiaque
quand j'ai revu mes enfants pour la
première fois je n'arrivais pas à croire
qu'ils étaient si grands je ne les
connaissais pas je devais apprendre à
les connaître à nouveau
deux mois après sa guérison Gary et
Catherine ont renouvelé leurs promesses
de mariage
il a découverte de son trouble de
personnalité multiple le laisser plein
de remords
il se sentait coupable de tout ce temps
passé loin de sa famille
j'ai l'impression d'avoir abandonné mes
enfants
de ne pas avoir été près de d'avoir
aussi abandonné Catherine ma femme que
j'ai laissé seul avec toute cette peine
mais je n'y peux rien je suis c'était
juste dysfonctionnement de mon corps qui
se partageait en deux trois et que
sais-je encore le trouble de la
personnalité multiple est l'une des
maladies les plus mystérieuses de
l'esprit en ce qui concerne Gary
pourquoi a-t-il vécu ces différentes
personnalités quelles en étaient les
causes
[Musique]
les psychiatres expliquent ce phénomène
étrange de plusieurs façons certaines
personnes développent ce genre de
personnalités alternatives en réponse à
un trop grand traumatisme ou à une trop
importante tension ils appellent ce
processus la dissociation
les gens sous tension parlent d'une
sensation de vide comme s'il n'était
plus eux-mêmes mais lors d'une tension
extrêmement forte il y a cassure dans
l'esprit et il vivent réellement ce
qu'il décrivent mais ils n'en sont plus
conscients ils ne peuvent plus analyser
leur émotion comme il pourrait le faire
une personne qui a un esprit saint
beaucoup restent inexpliqué au sujet de
ces désordrementaux mais une chose est
sûre tous les cas de troubles de
personnalités multiples proviennent de
traumatismes de l'enfance
pour Gary d'après sa femme il aurait
subi des abus sexuels
[Musique]
et ainsi que pour beaucoup son trouble
s'est révélé lors d'un traumatisme à
l'âge adulte
l'horrible douleur de regarder sa fille
mourir la sans doute conduit à se
dissocier de son statut d'adulte
aujourd'hui Gary ne se souvient pas de
ses six années comme mairie ni de
l'université une perte de mémoire quasi
totale de 11 ans
en prenant une autre personnalité les
malades fuient leur tension ou leur
traumatisme et n'ont donc plus à y faire
face et à les gérer c'est comme un
système d'autodéfense en cas de grand
danger
il est difficile de dire pourquoi Gary a
choisi de revenir
son psychologue explique que pour
quelques raisons inconscientes Gary
s'est senti suffisamment fort pour
affronter la vérité
désormais Gary se calme lui-même quand
il se sent tendu même si sa famille
affirme qu'elle est prête à vivre avec
la partie de Marie en lui la partie du
bébé je les aime tous les trois bien sûr
je préfère mon papa mais vous savez nous
n'avons pas le choix nous devons
l'accepter je ne vais pas mentir
j'espère seulement que si quelque chose
arrive il ne sera pas longtemps mari ou
le bébé parce que c'est quand même
totalement irréaliste
[Musique]
c'est comme l'épée de Damoclès au-dessus
de votre tête vous ne savez jamais de
quoi l'heure ou la minute suivante sera
faite vraiment quelquefois vous avez une
peur bleue maintenant examinons le cas
d'une jeune fille dont la personnalité
alternative et suicidaire
le trouble de la personnalité multiple
est difficile à diagnostiquer parce que
le plus souvent caché au fond de
l'esprit qui lui-même lutte pendant des
années contre la dépression les
tendances suicidaires la drogue ou
l'alcool
la personne mène souvent une vie
tourmentée et désespérée
quand Valérie Durkin avait 16 ans
c'était une droguée et une alcoolique
elle a traversé l'enfance a Philadelphie
entre abus sexuel et traumatisme
Valérie c'est toujours senti en conflit
avec ses demi-sœurs et sa mère
alcoolique
a bien essayé de se sortir de tous ces
démons en assistant toutes les semaines
à des discussions et des rencontres avec
un psychothérapeute
mais au cœur résultat
et elle a commencé à ressentir des vides
et des pertes de mémoire
et bientôt une autre personnalité à
surgit menaçant sa vie
Valérie se rappelle très bien avoir
marché dans un petit couloir exigu et de
s'être blotti dans un coin
mais elle ne se souvient pas d'avoir
englouti 60 cachés dans le cabinet
médical de sa mère elle sait juste
sentie comme une toute petite fille je
me sentais tellement vulnérable et
blessée j'avalais en demandant juste à
Dieu de me pardonner mais je ne pouvais
faire autrement je ne voulais pas
vraiment mourir et je ne savais même pas
pourquoi j'étais dans ce cabinet médical
sa mère l'a trouvé et lui a sauvé la vie
valérie est rentré chez elle
elle a continué le collège et deux ans
d'université avant d'avoir à nouveau
besoin d'aide
cette fois-ci elle demande elle-même son
internement dans un hôpital
psychiatrique de l'Arizona
valérie est déclaré maniaco-dépressive
et son traitement médicamenteux est très
lourd ce qui la met dans un état hébété
et souvent dépressif à sa sortie elle
revient avec joie à l'université
à cette période elle était épanouie et
calme
je me sentais bien et j'aimais cet
univers de compétition de travail de
défis et tout ce monde universitaire
pendant toutes ces années j'étais très
heureuse
mais vers la fin de ces études
supérieures Valérie subit un brusque
changement son intérêt pour sa scolarité
s'amenuise elle passe ses nuits dehors
[Musique]
une amie d'université voyait bien la
personnalité de Valérie évoluée mais
elle a pensé que son ami était juste un
peu lunatique
quelques semaines mais quand je la
revoyais je ressentais toujours cette
impression elle était différente sur de
nombreux points elle n'avait plus la
même vision des choses les mêmes centres
d'intérêt les mêmes amis et même sa
garde-robe était changée
puis un soir Valérie se trouvant
d'humeur en jouet a décidé d'aller
danser avec une amie
et soudain alors que la soirée semblait
agréable de façon totalement
inexplicable Valérie devient suicidaire
[Musique]
j'étais à jeun vous savez je n'avais
rien vu j'étais juste là dans cette
boîte et j'ai regardé mon ami et lui ai
dit je veux m'ouvrir le ventre et
pourtant je ne voulais pas mourir elle a
tout de suite pensé que nous devions
aller aux urgences
aux urgences Valérie agissaient au début
comme une petite fille
puis sa personnalité d'adulte a émergé
le médecin lui a demandé si on lui avait
déjà dit qu'elle était atteinte de
personnalités multiples c'est quoi
Valérie a répondu non
je n'ai pas plusieurs personnes au fond
de moi elle m'a juste regardé avec
gentillesse en souriant parce que je ne
savais pas que ces personnalités lui
avaient parlé après cet incident le
psychiatre de Philadelphie un
diagnostiqué que Valérie souffrait du
trouble de la personnalité multiple
elle a passé les trois années suivantes
avec de lourds soins en externe
mais vers la fin Valérie ne se soigne
même plus
[Musique]
de ce fait dans l'année et demi qui
suivit son psychiatre a découvert une
cinquantaine de personnalités
alternatives sous hypnose Valérie a
révélé son enfance terrifiante d'abus
sexuels et de cul de satanique
un après-midi en faisant le ménage dans
son appartement Valérie a découvert un
journal et des dessins qu'elle avait
réalisé sous une de ces personnalités
alternatives les écrits et les dessins
torturés l'ont épouvanté
son état empiré elle se rendait compte
qu'elle avait besoin d'une nouvelle
forme de traitement
[Musique]
à 36 ans Valéry entre à l'hôpital
chatter de Dallas afin de trouver un
traitement pour la soigner
les médecins se concentrent alors sur
ces problèmes actuels plus que sur son
passé
[Musique]
au début Valérie ne croyait pas qu'elle
souffrait de trouble de la personnalité
aussi a-t-elle demandé un suivi vidéo de
sa thérapie
ici nous voyons une de ces personnalités
relâchant toutes ces émotions profondes
[Applaudissements]
10 minutes plus tard apparaît une petite
fille apeurée
où est mon papa
[Musique]
le passage en petite fille durera 45
minutes
la découverte par son docteur de la
non-vérité de son souvenir d'enfant sur
le satanisme fut un moment décisif dans
la thérapie de Valérie ses souvenirs ont
réussi gérés lors de son premier passage
sous hypnose
cette révélation lui permet de se
consacrer uniquement sur la seule cause
de son dérèglement émotionnel l'abus
sexuel
[Musique]
le cas de Valéry souligne deux points
importants elle a eu très tôt des
problèmes sérieux dans sa vie qui ont
entraîné des symptômes de la
personnalité multiple mais il apparaît
aussi que la thérapie peut parfois
amplifier et augmenter les dérèglements
les rendant pire qu'ils ne le sont
après 18 mois les barrières entre ces
personnalités multiples ont semblé
s'atténuer
ces processus appelés intégration peut
être long et douloureux
la guérison des troubles de la
personnalité multiple et similaire à
celle de l'alcoolisme vous devez le
vouloir réellement être vraiment motivé
et vous devez savoir que vous aurez
accomplir un travail de force si vous
êtes bien préparé alors vous pourrez
réussir
Valérie n'a pas totalement récupéré elle
n'est pas encore complètement elle-même
mais ces médecins affirment que les
résultats sont prometteurs
comment est-il possible pour Valérie ou
d'autres souffrant de cette même maladie
de redevenir une personne normale
j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire que les
chances de réintégration dans une vie
normale au milieu des autres de la
communauté et de ses proches est
possible mais c'est actuellement le plus
gros problème rencontré par toutes les
personnes ayant souffert du trouble de
la personnalité multiple
la guérison des patients atteints de ce
trouble de la personnalité dépend de la
gravité du cas et du psychiatre
pour Valérie les diverses thérapies qui
l'ont encouragé à croire de faux
souvenirs s'avèrent pire
quand les médecins ne font pas la
distinction entre le désir inconscient
du patient et la réalité la thérapie
aggrave au lieu de soulager
il est intéressant de voir que si les
thérapeutes n'agissent pas pour le bien
de leur patient leurs avocats
interviennent c'est en effet de plus en
plus souvent le cas maintenant les
patients ou les parents de ceux-ci
accusent leur médecin des suites
négatives de leur thérapie
cette pression permettra plus de rigueur
dans les diagnostics et les traitements
dans le cas de Valérie quand elle s'est
sentie sauvée et à nouveau dans le
présent et la commencer à aller de mieux
en mieux
vous devez dire non à cette maladie vous
devez vous obliger au calme vous savez
ce n'est pas évident pour quelqu'un qui
est un survivant d'un bouleversement
complet de tout son être pour quelqu'un
dans la tension a toujours été en
survoltage le silence peut être très
redoutable et le calme un stress de
solitude il faut toujours doser prendre
ce qu'il y a de mieux dans chaque
situation
voyons maintenant la femme qui a inspiré
le livre et le film les trois
personnalités d'Eve elle a vécu avec
différentes personnalités pendant près
de 40 ans
Chris is more femme mère artiste
accomplie et conférencière a souffert du
trouble de la personnalité multiple
pendant 45 ans aujourd'hui il est
complètement guéri et son parcours est
un décalé plus fameux dans l'histoire
médicale
sa douloureuse épreuve a inspirer le
livre les trois personnalités d'Eve et
un OSCA pour le film avec l'actrice John
wood World en 1957
ce film a été réalisé par son psychiatre
le docteur Corbett big Pen en 1953 en ce
temps-là le trouble de la personnalité
multiple était peu connu
ce passage relate la première bataille
du Christ avec sa maladie mentale
voulez-vous continuer ainsi
pourquoi non
parce que c'est pas normal d'être un SI
l'histoire de Chris is more a commencé
en Caroline du Sud pendant la dépression
enfant elle a été le témoin d'une série
d'événements tragiques
[Musique]
tout d'abord à l'âge de deux ans et la
vue le corps de noyer dans un fossé
puis quelques semaines plus tard elle
est le témoin d'un homme se faisant
couper en deux dans une scierie
après ces deux incidents à 3e un
accident survenu à sa mère ce qui dira
Chris ensuite a été le déclenchement de
son désordre mental
[Musique]
j'ai vu ma mère se coupait gravement le
bras et me demander d'aller chercher mon
père sauf qu'à la plage je me suis jetée
sur un lit et j'ai enflé ma tête sous
l'oreiller et alors j'ai vu cette autre
petite fille aller chercher papa c'est
là mon premier souvenir d'avoir quitté
mon corps pour le laisser à quelqu'un
d'autre
à partir de là les différentes
personnalités de Christ prendraient le
contrôle de sa vie chacune avec un rôle
distinct
[Musique]
s émotionnels semblent se transformer en
un personnage créé de toutes pièces
ces personnes individuelles paraissent
acquérir des noms et des identités et
finissent par être reconnues par les
autres comme des individus réels
cet arrangement a commencé tôt dans
l'enfance de Christ quand ces
personnalités se sont manifestées
elles-mêmes par groupe de trois une
gentille petite fille une méchante et
une indifférence
[Musique]
en 1940 se trouble n'était pas connu du
tout la famille et les amis ont juste
pensé que ces problèmes venaient
seulement d'une légère tendance au
mensonge et à l'exagération
Chris était mis à l'écart par ceux de
son âge et les adolescents
elle a quitté le collège en classe de
10e élémentaire parce que beaucoup de
ces personnalités alternatives ont
détesté l'école entre temps et la vêtue
21 ans était devenue une femme et une
mère
d'autres signes de sa maladie
apparaissent bien vite après son mariage
elle devenait dangereuse non pour
elle-même mais pour sa petite fille ta
fille
ce sont des situations nouvelles de
stress qui ont fait naître ces autres
personnalités un jour ta fille alors
âgée de quatre ans s'est mise à crier
crise a pris l'accord de naster et a
essayé d'étrangler sa fille
son mari est intervenu Chris était
désorienté et a juré qu'elle n'avait pas
le moindre souvenir de ce qui s'était
passé
ces événements ont convaincu Christ
d'entrée à l'hôpital d'Augusta en
Géorgie ou le docteur Corbett tikpen a
très vite conclu qu'elle possédait trois
personnalités
il les a appelés
la mer elle était extrêmement puritaire
tout l'opposé de F black qui elle est
méchante et prendre du bon temps
est arrivé plus mûr plus intellectuel
que les deux autres
thérapie ces trois personnalités ont mué
en une seule
son médecin pensait qu'elle était guérie
entre temps Chris avait divorcé et
c'était remarié et elle avait déménagé
dans le Tennessee
son cas fut un sujet d'étude pendant
trois ans et en 1957 le docteur tikpen
fait de ses recherches un best-seller
qui devint le film les trois
personnalités d'Eve bien que le film est
attiré l'attention du public sur cette
maladie de la personnalité multiple
Chris n'en a jamais eu les retomber
financières et resta toujours anonyme
Hollywood nous montre un film qui finit
bien mais la maladie de Christ au
contraire s'est développée de nouvelles
personnalités alternatives sont apparues
contraignant Christ à suivre une autre
thérapie et sa famille à s'adapter à
chacune d'elles
[Musique]
everyone je reconnaissais chaque
personnalité de ma mère et elles étaient
toutes ma mère la dame pour prêter ma
préférée sans doute parce qu'elle se
montrait très maternelle et elle prenait
soin de moi et puis il y avait la fille
aux fraises c'était une femme stupide
arrogante dure cruelle et impolie pour
elle je n'existais pas
pour beaucoup les troubles de la
personnalité multiple ne se manifeste
pas seulement dans les vêtements et les
manières mais aussi par des différences
psychologiques
au fil des années la famille de Chris
l'a entouré et soutenu
très vite nous avons voulu vivre comme
une famille normale et aider notre mère
nous essayons de passer par-dessus de
tout faire pour atténuer et diminuer ses
crises mais il nous était difficile
d'imaginer que cela pourrait un jour se
terminer mais en 1974 après plus de 20
ans de thérapie Chris à une rémission il
lui semble qu'elle peut enfin contrôler
sa vie
c'est arrivé d'un seul coup voilà ce que
vous devez faire être une personne
responsable qui ne passe pas d'un
personnage à l'autre j'ai le désirais
tellement quelqu'un de semblable à ce
que doivent être tous les gens
pour vraiment se retrouver il lui a
fallu subir des tests multiples sur la
mémoire
un beau jour l'Esprit de Christ s'est
retrouvé à sa place elle se sentait
guérie
je me sentais comme dans un rêve tous
intégrait tout reprenait sa place comme
si je revenais à la vie
pour la famille aussi cette guérison
apporta des changements
pendant quelques mois on a eu
l'impression de vivre sur une autre
planète d'intégrer le fait que nous
ayons une mère normale je ne sentais pas
que c'était mes enfants je savais bien
qu'ils étaient bien sûr mais ces
sentiments d'amour d'attention d'insta
maternel n'existait pas chez moi je ne
savais pas ce que c'était
aujourd'hui à plus de 70 ans Chris eyes
a vécu que près de 25 ans dans la peau
d'une personne normale
je sais que je suis à condensé de 22
personnalités différentes mais je suis
plus que cela aujourd'hui j'ai atteint
ma vraie personnalité durant ces 25
dernières années
les psychiatres disent bien que le plus
difficile à gérer dans une guérison et
ce passage de toutes ces personnalités
en une seule
qu'elle fut l'épreuve de Chris azmin
le point commun de toutes les guérisons
et cette sensation de perte et de
tristesse comme lorsque vous perdez un
ami
pour bon nombre de malades atteints de
personnalités multiples l'intégration
devient une sorte de deuil ils doivent
combattre la perte de même
malheureusement à l'heure actuelle il
n'existe aucune assurance sur la non
réapparition de ces troubles
en fait nous ne savons pas ce qui se
passe quand un patient guéri a-t-il
vraiment récupéré de ses personnalités
multiples ou a-t-il encore plus de
traumatismes on imagine qu'il est plus à
même de dissocier ces différentes
personnalités à force de les connaître
ou alors toutes les thérapies subies
l'ont aidé à se sentir fort et combatif
le taux du succès de guérison des
personnalités multiples étant hausse
mais au regard de l'histoire de Chris
eyes mort l'intégration peut être très
longue
[Musique]
j'ai mené un combat très dur pendant des
années pour guérir mais je le ferai
encore s'il le fallait car voyez-vous
j'ai maintenant une vie formidable une
vraie paix que sans doute peu de gens
connaissent
le trouble de la personnalité multiple a
été révélée au grand public par le film
les trois personnalités d'Eve mais c'est
en 1973 grâce au livre Sybille que les
gens prennent vraiment conscience du
traumatisme laissé par les abus sexuels
de l'enfant
Sybille serait le pseudonyme d'un
étudiant en art de l'Université de
Colombia à New York
l'auteur Flora retache ryber raconte la
vie d'une femme qui ayant subi dans un
enfance des préjudices sexuels éclatent
en 16 personnalités
[Musique]
d'après le livre Sybille serait la
survivante d'une vie effroyable peuplée
de passage à vide brutaux et terrifiant
en 1976 une mini-série télévisée tirée
du livre est apparue elle a beaucoup
contribué à faire connaître ses troubles
de la personnalité multiple jusqu'à
l'heure peu connu
25 ans plus tard au printemps 1998 un
autre cas est apparu dans les médias
peterswell un history en psychanalyse et
son collègue Michael borsche Jacobsen un
professeur de littérature à l'Université
de Washington découvrez que
l'aspiratrice du fameux Livre et de la
série télévisée était une artiste nommée
Shirley Hardel Mason
[Musique]
du livre en fait elle s'avérait beaucoup
plus intéressante plus complexe à la
parole puissante un être plus profond
aussi
[Musique]
révélations quelques toiles de Messenger
dans une galerie à New York pour soi
alors une exploitée à renforcer sa
recherche et la convaincu que la civile
du roman était fictive d'après lui
Shirley Mason n'aurait jamais souffert
de personnalités multiples
les 16 personnalités qu'elle est censée
posséder auraient été encouragés par son
thérapeute le docteur Cornelia Wilbert
il était évident que Shirley ne
souffrait du trouble de personnalité
multiple que dans un cadre
psychothérapeutique
tous ceux connaissant Charlet ne
l'avaient jamais vu dans une autre
personnalité
d'autre part elle aimait énormément
correspondre avec de nombreuses
personnes et bien figurez-vous que
durant ces 11 années de psychanalyse
elle écrivait d'une manière très
cohérente et claire et elle signait
chacune de ces lettres par Shirley
mais bien avant que si Bill est commencé
à être connu elle avait beaucoup de
doutes se demandant si elle souffrait
réellement de ce trouble
le docteur Herbert Spiegel psychiatre
soignait si billes quand son thérapeute
habituel Cornelia Wilbert partait en
vacances il affirme en 1990 sept qu'elle
ne souffre pas de personnalités
multiples elle réagit seulement
violemment sous hypnose et à l'ENA
fragile d'après lui les différentes
personnalités de la civile du livre
aurait été suggérées par une partie de
la thérapie du docteur Wilbert
[Musique]
chez cette elle me disait Hélène ce à
quoi je répondais pourquoi le
pensez-vous elle me répondait que
lorsqu'elle se trouvait avec le docteur
Wilbur il lui semblait que c'était ce
qu'elle attendait de Shirley qu'elle
soit Hélène je lui disais qu'elle
n'avait pas à faire cela elle rétorquait
bien puisque je ne peux pas le faire
alors je ne le veux pas puis elle a
ajouté mais est-ce que c'est bien de
faire cela sans être Hélène oui lui ai
dit immédiatement
Spiegle a voulu provoquer une rencontre
entre l'auteur de Sybille Flora retache
ryber et son co-auteur la thérapeute de
messen Cornelia Wilber mais elles ont
décliné l'offre
lorsque j'ai affirmé que Shirley ne
souffrait pas de la personnalité
multiple je Schreiber s'est opposé elle
disait mais si vous remettez en cause le
fait que mon héroïne soit atteinte de
cette maladie la série ou même le livre
ne se vendra plus mon éditeur veut qu'il
en soit ainsi je lui ai répondu ne
croyez-vous pas que c'est une raison
odieux
peut-être mais ça ne développait pas les
troubles de la personnalité multiple
mais elle a pris des particularités
cliniques en suivant la thérapie de son
médecin le docteur Wilbert
les chercheurs pensent que dans certains
processus de la psychanalyse à l'heure
mutuelle peut se développer entre le
patient et son médecin
la mort de Sherley messeng il a Wilbert
et de Schreiber empêcha la découverte de
la vérité jusqu'à ce que les archives de
Wilbers furent trouvés dans les années
il ne faisait aucun doute que mes sonne
souffrait de sérieux problèmes
émotionnels mais jusqu'à quel point ces
personnalités multiples venaient-elles
vraiment de sa thérapie
[Musique]
elle aurait pu faire semblant d'être
malade juste pour plaire au docteur
villebur ou prétendre ne pas l'être
alors qu'elle l'était pour plaire cette
fois au docteur Spiegel mais nous ne
possédons pas suffisamment de preuves
pour affirmer quoi que ce soit
selon le docteur Ross les tentatives
pour essayer à tout prix de trouver des
troubles de la personnalité multiple
nuisent aux meilleurs intérêts du
patient
l'important est de sortir de l'esprit du
malade qu'il souffre de personnalités
multiples par l'analyse de ces
personnalités multiples d'insister et de
le convaincre que la personnalité
multiple ne sera jamais la réalité le
désordre émotionnels est toujours créé
par l'Esprit dans un but précis la
thérapie doit le découvrir et ainsi
aider le patient à vivre mieux et plus
normalement
en 1980 les troubles de la personnalité
multiple seront reconnus comme une
maladie réelle par l'Association
Américaine en psychiatrie mais combien
de personnes en souffrent-elles
les experts affirment que depuis la
publication de Sybille en 1973 au moins
40 000 cas ont été recensés presque tous
en Amérique du Nord
ayant réussi à vaincre leurs démons
intérieurs Shirley Mason écrit sizema
vécurent tout à fait normalement
pour Gary et Valérie ils sont sur le
chemin de la guérison
beaucoup de traumatismes se forment aux
âges extrêmement vulnérables mes
amystère restant entier pourquoi
certains enfants victimes d'abus sexuels
développent-ils des personnalités
multiples et d'autres pas
d'une façon ou d'une autre je ne sais
combien d'enfants sont victimes chaque
année de traumatismes
de manière épisodique ou répétitive mais
tous ne souffrent pas ensuite de ces
troubles de personnalité multiple la
plupart d'entre eux d'ailleurs alors
pourquoi ce petit nombre nous ne savons
Pascal a écrit un jour le cœur a ses
raisons que la raison ne connaît pas la
réponse est toujours nous ne savons pas
[Musique]